- Bro, I’m hungover. I can’t play today.
I’m throwin’ up before the game.
You know, I get it all outta my system.
- This is crazy.
- Yeah, it’s so crazy because that was
the best game I ever had in the NFL.
♪♪♪
- Clinton Portis!
- What’s good, man?
- We got a Washington legend, a Hurricane great.
You grow up playin’ pool?
- Man, this is my first time.
- You sure this your first time?
- First time.
I was practicing outside.
- [Laughing]
Your rookie year with the Denver Broncos:
Take me through what happened rookie night.
- Oh, it’s most epic rookie night of all time, right?
So Al Wilson, Shannon Sharpe, Rod Smith,
uh, Brian Griese—everybody came out.
In Denver, the entire team partied together.
- Say less.
- So you got the squad, everybody was there.
It was like, “Man, we gonna have rookie night,
we gotta do this right,” you know?
Oh, you get the vets out, you know,
they gonna get ‘em a bottle of Champagne.
You know, they, they do it big. They did it right.
- What bottle of Champagne we talkin’?
- Back then, I think it was Moet. Like, Moet was big.
You know, rookie night, you’re supposed to be reasonable—
- Of course.
- On the tab.
- But our tab probably was, it was 20 grand.
- What do you spend $20,000 on?!
- Grey Goose and Hennessy.
- Yeah, dawg.
- [Laughing]
- Back, back then at 21, 22, you were definitely on Hennessy.
- You mixin’ up dark and clear?
- You young.
- Yeah.
- When you’re young, you’re drinkin’ anything.
You just tryna have a good time.
But Friday night probably lasted till 5 a.m. Saturday morning.
I ended up bein’ sick on Sunday.
- What does sick mean?
- I was hungover on Sunday.
- [Laughing]
- So I was in worse condition on Sunday than I was Friday or Saturday.
- Damn.
- Like, it’s one of those, “Bro, I can’t play in this game.”
And I’m gettin’ ready to walk into Coach Shanahan’s office,
and as I walked to his office, Shannon Sharpe say, “Po! What you doing?”
I’m like, “Man, I can’t play.”
He was like, “Ohhhh, no!”
Like, that, “That’s not their problem.
You still gotta go out and perform.”
So I’m like, “What?”
He was like, “Man, don’t do that. Go outside, run it out.”
He was like, “Come back in, uh, contrast whirlpools.
Hot, cold, hot, cold until you feel better.”
So I go outside, and I’m sprintin’
up and down the sideline—this is before the game,
I’m runnin’ 100-yard sprints full speed.
Come back in, hurlin’ everywhere, you know, but I’m startin’ to feel better.
You know, I get it all outta my system.
- This is crazy.
- Yeah, it’s so crazy because that was the best game I ever had in the NFL.
I had 17 carries for 228
against Arizona, and I was hungover. Like, totally done.
That was in 2002, by mistake, rookie night, right?
So now you speed up, maybe 2006?
This “famous” shot game, the Henny game.
- With your U teammates.
You got yourself, Santana Moss and Sean Taylor,
in D.C., in Washington.
- We’re playin’ the Jacksonville Jaguars.
Me and Tana sittin’ in the, in the parking lot.
So, you know, we gettin’ turnt in the car.
I’m like, “Man, I’m finna take another shot of Henny.”
And, of course, we tell Sean, like, “Bro, we gonna take a shot.
We gotta go out—like, we gotta win this game.”
So me, Sean and Tana, we toast, take a shot.
Tana scored two touchdowns and game-winning touchdown, right?
Sean had a crazy game.
I had a crazy game. Another 100-yard game
against one of the better defenses in the NFL.
- How often did you guys do this ritual?
- It wasn’t like, “This is what we look forward to.
This is what we did every week,” you know?
It was just, if we had one of those games,
like, “Man, I gotta go ball out. Cheers.”
And we out.
- Man.
This ain't your first time, bro.
There's no way in hell this your first time, man.
- I'm learnin' on the run, man.
- Nah.
Thanks for kickin' it with us.
Subscribe to B/R
to check out more dope videos like this one.